to allow people to fall in love with who  they are at a natural state it starts  with the personality with all the things  that make you unique and then after you  get through embodying that and really  being there for yourself really loving  yourself your expression blesses all  life because you understand there is no  better or worse there is no place for  Judgment of another life form and their  choices so you know we can just relax  and we can develop that devotional  reverence for the privilege of being in  a life and then we can just have a  respect for all life even things we  don't agree with or  um you know it's not our preference you  know the greatest Miracle exists within  the human body the Ascension is  happening inside it's an incention we're  not going anywhere we're activating more  of Who We Are